hello good afternoon flights to the uk
from six african countries have now been
suspended as the government tries to
ensure a new variant of coronavirus does
not reach the uk
in the past our belgium has confirmed
its identified one case of the news
train which is feared could be more
transmissible than the delta variant
while speaking the house of commons this
morning health secretary sergey javid
said the uk must act now with caution
we are concerned that this new variant
may pose substantial risk to public
health
the variant has an unusually large
number of mutations
yesterday the uk health security agency
classified
b1152
as a new variant under investigation
and the variant technical group has
designated it as a variant under
investigation with very high priority
it's the only variant with this
designation making it higher priority
than beta
it shares many of the features of alpha
beta and delta variants
early indications show
this variant may be more transmissible
than the delta variant
and current vaccines may be less
effective against it
it may also impact the effectiveness of
one of our major treatments rhonaprief
speaking earlier the world health
organization warned against hastily
imposed travel restrictions calling for
countries to adopt a risk-based approach
countries can do a lot already in terms
of surveillance and sequencing and work
together with affected countries or
globally
to work scientifically to fight
this variant and to understand more
about it so that we know how to go about
so at this point um again implementing
travel measures is being cautioned
against
well as of midday all flights from
namibia botswana zimbabwe la soto at
suartini and south africa have been
suspended from sunday new arrivals in
the uk will be required to quarantine in
hotels
those returning before then must isolate
at home while passengers who've come
back from those countries in the last 10
days are being asked to do a pcr test
the south african government has
criticized the travel ban calling it
rushed well our correspondent charlotte
nomans joins us now from the newsroom so
charlotte what's causing the most
concern then for government and
scientists
well as you heard from the health
secretary uh shadow david there the real
cause of concern is the fact that this
variant has such a high level of
mutations double the amount from the
dominant delta variant and that means
it's likely to be able to evade vaccines
more easily and therefore spread more
quickly between person to person so
that's why this is causing so much
concern and why the government is acting
quickly to try and contain the spread
they're imposing these travel uh
restrictions on those six african uh
countries and asking people uh to then
quarantine um as of 4 am on sunday in
the uh hotels so we're seeing the return
of the red list and while at the moment
no uk cases we are seeing this variant
spread to others and that's what
scientists are worried about about the
rapid spread of this variant and they're
not taking any chances with it we've
also heard from the health secretary
that they are open for discussion
perhaps more countries will be added to
that red list and they're keeping all
avenues open and then we'll just have to
wait to see really not a lot is known at
this current stage about this fair and
it could take some weeks before
scientists no more charlotte thank you
scientists are concerned about the new
variant due to the number of mutations
that have been identified well let's
take a look now at what we know so far
59 cases of the variant have been
officially recorded in south africa hong
kong and botswana but this figure could
be higher and it's expected to rise
scientists say the variant has 50
mutations overall and 32 on the spike
protein which is the target of the most
vaccines meaning that they could become
less or even ineffective
scientists also say the variance does
show up on a pcr test
well our science editor tom clark has
the latest
it's certainly very concerning there's
no doubt about that there's no other way
of describing it but we have to be
cautious in sort of how we uh
react to that concern at the moment
because we just don't know and there
have been very worrying looking variants
that have come along before and come to
nothing if you remember the beta or
south africa very look very concerning
caused a big surge of cases in south
africa but it couldn't compete with the
far more transmissible infectious delta
variant which we now live with every day
in the uk and has become the dominant
strain globally
but the reason for the concern with this
one it's got lots of mutations twice as
many mutations that are probably linked
to evading the immune system and big
heat better infecting cells than the
delta variant that's dominant um so
theoretically it immediately emerges
concern and what really changed things
yesterday was when the south africans
used a new
a new way of analyzing their data to see
that
part of the spike of cases they're now
seeing particularly in halting province
appears to be linked to this variant
they've seen a doubling in a number of
cases of this variant and that's
what sort of caused the alarm there are
other epidemiological reasons for why
that could be happening that's not
linked to this there being
more transmissible
but we need to be prudent for the time
being hence the travel bans hence the
reaction we're having now remember the
government was definitely slow to act in
delaying the entry of the south african
area of the india variant now delta
bearing into the uk
but remember it's important to say we
can't keep these things out we know that
travel bans aren't universally effective
at keeping viruses out this could slow
it down and buy us some time and that's
why we're doing that while we figure out
in fact whether it is going to evade our
vaccines or causes a particular problem
it may just like others not be able to
out-compete delta